at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
books i've loved on the tim ferriss show
is exclusively brought to you by
audible there couldn't be a better
sponsor for this series my dear
listeners and readers
i have used audible for so many years as
long as i can remember i love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet i listen when
i'm taking walks
i listen while i'm cooking i listen
whenever i can
and if you're looking for a place to
start i can recommend three of my
favorites
the first is the tao of seneca
by seneca if you want to hear my
favorite letters of all time
touches on stoic philosophy calmness
under duress
etc the next is the graveyard book by
neil
gaiman g-a-i-m-a-n one of my favorites
even if you're a non-fiction
purist this is the fiction book that you
need to listen to
neil also has perhaps the most calming
voice of all time
and third greg mcewen's essentialism
subtitled the disciplined pursuit of
less this is one of my favorite books of
the past few years combines
very well with the 80 20 principle but
more on audible
every month audible members get one
credit for any audio book on the site
plus a choice of multiple audible
originals from a rotating selection they
also get access to daily news digests
from the likes of the new york times
wall street journal and the washington
post
as well as guided meditation programs
and here are some other amazing audible
features and i use a bunch of these you
can download titles and listen offline
anytime
anywhere i use this feature
even when i could get access i'll put my
phone on say airplane mode
because i don't want to get bothered
with notifications and i'm taking a walk
to clear my head
and you can listen to your titles
offline in a case like that or on a
plane or whatever obviously i'm not
flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and tablets you can
listen across devices without losing
your spot
and whispersync is another feature i use
quite a lot i love reading my kindle in
bed for instance
then picking up at the same exact spot
where i left off when i go walking and
listening the next day
kindle and audio versions can be synced
up automatically it's just amazing
and if you can't decide what to listen
to don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them
for instance to binge on a whole series
if you like audible offers just about
everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a-list comedy and audible
originals you won't find
anywhere else and right now audible is
offering you guys
that's tim ferriss show listeners a free
audio book with a
30-day trial membership and
again my list if you want to check them
out the tao of seneca
the graveyard book essentialism those
are just three there's so many good ones
out there
just go to audible.com tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs
then download your free title and start
listening it's that easy let's check it
out go to audible.com
tim or text tim tim to
500 500 to get started today check it
out
audible.com tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is usually my job to sit down
with world-class performers of all
different types
startup founders investors chess
champions olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives
this episode however is an experiment
and part of a short form series that i'm
doing
simply called books i've loved i've
invited some amazing past
guests close friends and new faces to
share their favorite books
describe their favorite books the books
that have influenced them changed them
transform them for the better and i hope
you pick up one or two
new mentors in the form of books from
this new series and apply the lessons in
your own life
i had a lot of fun putting this together
inviting these people to participate
and have learned so so much myself i
hope that is also the case for you
please enjoy
my name is alain dubotel i'm a writer
and the founder of an organization
called
the school of life dedicated to
emotional fulfillment and
self-understanding
i want to talk about two books today
that mean a huge amount to me and that i
always press into the hands of pretty
much anyone that i meet
the first book is called home is where
we start from
and it's a collection of essays by a
wonderful english psychoanalyst
called donald winnicott and winnicott is
wise
on so many fronts but two of his ideas
stand out
in particular the first of his ideas
concerns what he calls
the true and the false self for
winnicott
all babies are born with the capacity to
express
winnicott's true self in other words to
express themselves fully
and without inhibition if they're sad
they're going to cry if they're angry
they might try and bite if they're happy
they'll giggle
but the point is a child at a very young
age
is almost definitely authentic it is
putting forward
its feelings as it experiences them it
is
unfiltered and this is what gives babies
their
their charm but also makes them
terrifying quite difficult to
to look after because they're just doing
exactly what they need to do when they
need to do it
there's no process of editing and this
is a process of engaging with what
donald winnicott famous child
psychoanalyst called the true
self now key for winnicott is the idea
that if you're going to grow up and be a
balanced
and healthy and authentic human being
you will need to have been given the
enormous privilege
of expressing your true self to those
around you
in the very earliest years that you were
on the planet all of us
need to have those moments when we can
be totally authentic
even at the cost of giving other people
a bit of a headache around us
we need some of this true self but
winnicott also observed his work with
children
that there is a danger that something
else happens
too soon and that is the birth of a
false
self now the full self is created out of
the expectations
of everyone around the small child
and there are all sorts of expectations
firstly that the child will be
good that the child will go to sleep on
time which really means
on the parent schedule that the child
will smile at grammy
that the child will at school be polite
to the teacher
and then um going on into later
childhood
will always follow certain rules writing
thank you letters
um being a good child now there are
obviously
good aspects to being a good child but
winnicott was very alive to the concept
of over early adaptation what he called
over compliance and for winnicott the
over-compliant
child has all sorts of problems what
happens is
that they are more attuned to the
demands of others than to their own
needs
and this can give them lots of
difficulties in later life
when they can no longer be authentic
they lose touch with what they really
want because what they really want
has been censored so heavily by those
around them in our world nowadays we
know all about rebels
and the problem with rebels you know
they're the ones who graffiti the
underpass and cause social problems and
we know how difficult this can be but
through the eyes of winnicott we can
also start to see another problem
and in a way it's perhaps a bigger
problem though it doesn't present itself
as such
and that is an excess of compliance in a
whole group of people
that we can call with nothing pejorative
being meant by this
the good boys and girls there are good
boys and girls everywhere and the
problem with good boys and girls is
they've been good too early they haven't
got
the bad out of their system they haven't
had a chance to express
themselves as they needed to in the
early years they weren't able
to bite when they wanted to bite to kick
when they wanted to kick to scream when
they wanted to scream
all the things that little babies and
infants do and shouldn't frighten anyone
by wanting to do
if all of that is suppressed with too
much energy there will be a problem so
winnicott the great patron saint of
being able
to get the right relative claims of the
true and the full self
a full self we all need one to navigate
adult life
but it only starts to make internal
sense
if we've also had a chance to express
the true self at another point
another great idea from winnicott is the
concept of
the good enough parent many parents came
to winnicott
very worried that they weren't doing a
good enough job as parents
they wanted to be better they were
worried that they weren't educating the
kid right or that
there was some eating problem or school
problem et cetera and
willy got could see that these worries
were actually getting in the way
of the parents doing um the you know the
fairly good job that they were
doing and so when it got made a
fascinating intervention first of all he
told parents
no child needs a perfect parent indeed a
perfect parent is very dangerous
it's a one-way route to psychosis to a
psychotic incident because
essentially the job of a parent is to
disappoint a child
bit by bit and induct them into adult
realities
if the parent is perfect how can the
child grow used to living
in the world that we all have to live in
which is a deeply imperfect one
so in an ideal world a good parent is
able
to break bad news well to the child
until the child can accept the whole
panoply of difficulties of adult life
amounting ultimately into the fact that
we are all mortal we are all going to
have to die
so um winnecock in order to capture what
he was trying to tell parents came up
with a wonderful phrase
he said no one needs a perfect parent
all they need is a good enough
parent and this phrase good enough is
the one that winicott launched into the
world and it's a highly useful one
because in
so many areas we don't need to be
perfect we just need to be good enough
we only need to be good enough workers
good enough friends
good enough colleagues and as i say good
enough
parents all of this comes from the very
down to earth beautifully written
and always highly useful and humane
wisdom
of donald winnicott and his wonderful
book home
is where we start from another book
that's very dear to me
is by arthur schopenhauer and it's
called essays
on the wisdom of life now arthur
schopenhauer is perhaps the most
pessimistic
of all the panoply of very pessimistic
german thinkers
that philosophy produced in that country
in the 19th century
he stands out for the unrelentingly
miserable tone
of his voice he says at one point it is
bad today tomorrow it will be worse
until the worst of all happens he says
at another point
that human life is completely
ill-adapted
to its purposes that no one can expect
to be happy ever
for more than five minutes at a time and
that
anyone who expects anything out of
romantic love
is sure to be completely disappointed
that nothing is true
that no friends can be constant um that
no career ambition will ever come right
i mean he
is the most miserable person on earth
however
reading him is a joy firstly he writes
beautifully he writes beautifully in
german there are some wonderful
translations into english
and there's something about somebody
articulating the most despairing
thoughts that brings us a huge amount of
comfort for a start we think i'm not
alone
all those suspicions you have often you
know three in the morning in despair or
uh gazing out of the um aeroplane window
in a low moment i mean just think what
on earth is the point of all this
well schopenhauer has been there he's
investigated the territory of despair
and he's put his flag all over it and it
is wonderful what he manages
to see most of us only glimpse despair
out of the corner of our eye and we
can't bear it
schopenhauer urges us to look despair in
the face make friends with it and also
laugh defiantly at it he's he's all the
time
sort of grinning slightly as he tells us
these dark
dark truths so often sadness comes about
because
we clash into an expectation of what
life should be like
that is simply contrary to what reality
can actually produce
and schopenhauer gently and with real
intelligence
nudges us towards a slightly more
pessimistic vision
of the world yes many of your dreams
won't come true yes
probably love won't work out for you
probably large aspects of your career
um won't come off uh probably many
people will disappoint you the world
will seem ugly and dumb
scherpenhauer is saying i know i know
i've been here
let's cry together rather than alone or
rather than escaping into a sentimental
bromide
that shields us from the fundamental
reality that we're engaged with so
this is your man at the moment of real
despair
he is the friend in darkness and oddly
strangely
he is immensely consoling um so these
are two books
uh by winnicott home is where we come
from and uh by schopenhauer essays on
the wisdom of life
that bring immense cheer in very
different ways to the
always confusing business of being alive
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could
include favorite articles that i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's four
hourworkweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one
and if you sign up i hope you enjoy